bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe du dos
et l'actualité de la semaine
c'est bien évidemment cette mer
méditerranée cette marenostrum qui
devient de plus en plus un cercueil pour
les migrants face à la tragédie
l'europe convoque un sommet
extraordinaire urgence oblige en 2015
un migrant meurt toutes les deux heures
en méditerranée
regardez le reportage
impressionnante opération de secours au
large de la grèce cette fois mais pas
seulement
les informations se suivent et se
ressemblent des centaines de migrants en
perdition au large de la libye
un appel au secours le drame de ces
naufragés à répétition est bien réel
celui survenu dans la nuit de samedi 18
au dimanche 19 avril a choqué par son
ampleur puis 100 morts selon le hcr
des hommes des femmes et enfants qui
périssent noyés
la semaine dernière il y a eu deux des
plus grave naufrage qu'on ait jamais
connu 400 personnes sont mortes et les
survivants sont arrivés à reggio de
calabre mardi matin et hier nous avons
appris la nouvelle des sept cents des
chiffres qui font froid dans le dos
trente cinq mille migrants sont arrivés
par bateau dans le sud de l'europe
depuis le début de l'année et 1600 sont
portées disparues le problème ici ce
n'est pas le nombre de réfugiés qui
arrivent par la mer l'année dernière
entre janvier et avril 26 mille 600
migrants sont arrivés cette année ils
étaient 22 mille migrants environ donc
le flux migratoire est resté le même
ce qui change c'est le nombre de morts
l'année dernière à la même époque il n'y
en avait 96 aujourd'hui il y en a mille
six cents c'est ça la grande différence
les candidats à l'exil viennent
essentiellement de libye de syrie ou
d'erythrée des pays en guerre où la
situation politique est loin d'être
stabilisé sur échasses c'est un
véritable enfer partout en libye
à partir du moment où tu es un étranger
le fait que tu soit blanc ou noir n'a
pas d'importance
tu n'es pas un citoyen tu es en enfer
l'union européenne est prête à
réexaminer la répartition des demandeurs
d'asile au sein des 28 et plus seulement
au sein des pays du sud
europe l'europe qui mise aussi sur la
formation d'un gouvernement stable en
libye principale porte de sortie vers
l'eldorado européen
alors nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
jean arthuis bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen président de la
commission des budgets ici au parlement
européen d'abord une réaction à la vue
de ces images de ces migrants contente
de se courir depuis les côtes grecques
ou même italiennes sont les tragédies
qui se multiplient les hommes des femmes
des familles des enfants qui fuient la
misère qui fuient la guerre
l'instabilité autour du bassin
méditerranéen
mais l'europe est mise en cause
l'opinion publique s'interroge que fait
l'europe et ils ont raison ce qui me met
en cause l'europe
je crois qu'ils ont raison mais ils
doivent mettre en cause la france et là
bas nous l'europe fonctionne le
gouvernement n'aura en fait y'a pas de
gouvernement en europe et l'image que
donne l'europe c'est l'image de
l'impuissance
c'est l'image pathétique des minutes de
silence
nous attendons une puissance européenne
et donc de la part des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement un engagement plus fort
et pourquoi une telle impuissance
on l'a dit les dragues ce que je répète
chefs d'états et de gouvernements
essaient de prolonger l'illusion qu'ils
auraient encore en mains des
prérogatives de souveraineté
diplomatiques militaires numérique
fiscale énergie faudrait intégrer tout
cela fait dire ça il faut fédérer
sinon nous donnerons l'image d'une
europe impuissante et l'europe deviendra
la cible et l'argumentaire de tous les
populistes donc il faut en sortir
ben la surveillance des frontières
fédérer une naturellement forcément est
donné à frontex les moyens de frontex a
besoin savez vous par exemple vous êtes
spécialiste du budget lorsqu'une h 30 si
bien ses 120 ans
l'opération triton à 40 la soirée des
lions mais c'est une infinie mans -
qu'était marenostrum auparavant c'est
120 millions par an c'est la moitié du
budget de la fédération française de
football
c'est un montant dérisoire
frontex est installé à varsovie il faut
savoir que c'est l'agent
une surveillance des frontières
surveille qui coordonne mais dont les
pouvoirs sont à 10 millions de budget
par mois absolument et normalement lors
c'était dérisoire donc lorsqu'un pays
accueille une agence ils signent une
convention de sièges pour faciliter les
conditions de vie des collaborateurs qui
ne sont pas du pays où est cette agence
eh bien il faut savoir que depuis onze
ans qu'existe frontex
la pologne n'a toujours pas signé la
convention de sièges ce qui complique
singulièrement l'accueil de
collaborateurs autre co polonais à
varsovie
donc il faut que l'europe bouge
incontestablement et il faudra en tirer
les conséquences au plan budgétaire
il faut qu'on ait les moyens est ce que
l'on appelle a les moyens de ses
ambitions but mais budgétairement
financière est à l'achat et en vigueur
des états isolément ne peuvent rien
faire et ils n'atteignent l'effectivité
de la souveraineté qu'en partageant
cette souveraineté
donc il y a urgence à faire bouger la
façon dont l'europe est politiquement
piloter faut aller vers ces pays d'où
partent les bateaux et coopérer avec les
autorités locales lorsqu'il y en a à
être présent pour empêcher le départ de
ces bateaux vous avez parlé d' urgence
justement le chef de l'état françois
hollande
on a parlé aussi de cette urgence je
vous propose de l'écouter on réagit
juste après
si nous ne traitons pas les causes même
de ceux qui produit ces drames
la première c'est que il y à un état la
libye qui n'est plus un état est donc
qui ne contrôle rien voire même qui
laisse faire il y a aussi des pays qui
sont à l'abandon je pense à l'erythrée
et avec des réfugiés qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux je pense aussi à ce qui se
produit au sel la france joue son rôle
donc nous faut traiter ces causes là et
puis il faut lutter contre le terrorisme
parce qu'il faut savoir que ceux qui
font les trafics qui mettent des
personnes sur des bateaux des bateaux
pourri des vaisseaux qui sont faits pour
disparaître en mer on en sait davantage
maintenant sur ce qui s'est passé sur la
méditerranée c'est à dire avec un bateau
où hélas les familles étaient enfermés
et ne pouvaient pas sortir lui ce sont
des terroristes et en luttant contre ces
trafiquants nous lutterons contre le
terrorisme en luttant contre le
terrorisme
nous lutterons contre ces trafiquants
parce qu'il se finance sur la misère du
monde se finance sur la détresse
il se finance sur la mort
genre tu ces filières d'immigration
clandestine c'est quelque part du du
terrorisme comme le dit le chef de
l'état
oui et si l'on veut lutter efficacement
contre le terrorisme
il faut qu'il y ait un pilotage
politique
un gouvernement ce qui est en cause
c'est la gouvernance de l'union
européenne j'espère qu'on en tirera les
leçons et qu'on trouvera les moyens de
travailler ensemble plus étroitement et
de mobiliser les moyens nécessaires pour
recréer les conditions de fonctionnement
normal d'un état dans tous ces pays qui
sont en difficulté également de
mobiliser des moyens appropriés pour le
développement de ce pays personne qui
tente de venir vers l'europe sont des
personnes qui fuient à la fois la guerre
et la misère et la misère économique
d'accord vous êtes aussi donc le
président de la commission des budgets a
aussi au parlement je voulais revenir
sur cette actualité aussi économique
avec goût le plan junkera plan qui vise
à booster l'économie dans l'union
européenne
seulement 315 milliards d'euros qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire il ya un
vote en plénière en juin si je ne
m'abuse
le parlement a été extrêmement prompt et
c'est mobiliser largement puisque nous
avons eu deux commissions qui ont
travaillé conjointement la commission
econ à la commission des budgets
nous y avons associé deux autres
commission tran et ittre et et neuf
autres commissions au total treize
commissions du parlement européen ont
travaillé ensemble pour rapidement
convenir d'un mécanisme permettant dès
l'été prochain
la mise en oeuvre du plan est au coeur
il s'agit de combler ce déficit
d'investissement qui affecte l'ensemble
de l'union européenne et on stimule en
investissement là où il peut activer
l'économie suisse face à la politique de
relance par alain renner a seulement de
la relance c'est vraiment de
l'investissement c'est de
l'investissement d'avenir c'est de la
recherche c'est des régions a
concrètement alors son transfert qui
nous écoutent cdc des réseaux de
communication ce sont des laboratoires
de recherche qu'on va aider ce sont des
pme auprès desquels
l'abbaye va pouvoir intervenir le fonds
européen d'investissement
c'est vraiment une mobilisation générale
315 milliards pour l'investissement pour
la croissance et pour l'emploi c'est
sans précédent nous allons entrer en
conciliation avec le conseil nous sommes
entrés dès ce matin en conciliation avec
le conseil et j'ai bon espoir que le 24
juin prochain le parlement européen va
pouvoir approuver ce mécanisme
permettant la mise en oeuvre la
mobilisation de ses moyens de ces
capitaux privés avec des garanties
consenties par l'union européenne et par
la banque européenne d'investissement
c'est je crois un message très fort il
faut que les états membres également
appuyé cette nécessaire confiance pour
que l'europe repartent de l'avant
merci jean martin aussant passionnés
jours sur le sujet merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation tout de suite place aux
magazines les élections législatives en
grande bretagne c'est pour bientôt c'est
le 7 mai un thème principal
l'immigration comme vous allez le
constater dans ce reportage de rim
benameur
ils sont pompiers musiciens avocat leur
point commun ce sont tous des immigrés
installés en grande bretagne et ils font
partie de la campagne
je suis un immigrant lancé par le
mouvement contre la xénophobie
quinze migrants ont pris la pause et
s'affiche fièrement dans 400 stations de
métro et bus à travers tout le pays
parmi eux wendy une biologiste
américaine arrivé il ya neuf ans elle
dénonce la montée du racisme en
angleterre qui pensaient les gens disent
des choses horribles des choses très
choquant comme tous les immigrés
devraient être renvoyés chez eux
mais ici c'est chez moi je n'irai nulle
part ailleurs c'est écoeurantes vues et
marché pour les associations de défense
des migrants il ya donc urgence à agir
ce projet a vu le jour grâce au
financement participatif en deux
semaines 44 mille livres collectés le
timing ne doit rien au hasard
la grande bretagne est en pleine
campagne pour les élections législatives
de mai le moment idéal pour faire passer
leur message
nous ne sommes pas pour l'ouverture
totale des frontières
nous sommes un mouvement responsable
mais nous voulons que les migrants ici
soient protégés et respectés et que ce
qu'ils apportent au royaume uni soit
valorisée donc c'est un message pour
tous les partis politiques
faites attention quand vous mentez sur
les immigrés
l'immigration est donc plus que jamais
au coeur de la campagne
après le succès du parti anti-européen
et anti-immigration you keep aux
dernières élections européennes
toutes les formations politiques se sont
emparés du sujet pour peter whittle
candidats de you keep dans cette
banlieue du sud de londres
son parti a simplement libéré la parole
mpshe a aidé ce n'est pas une campagne
anti immigrés c'est juste que le sujet
de l'immigration en angleterre a été
exclu du débat public
les gens avaient peur d'en parler parce
qu'ils étaient automatiquement traité de
raciste je peux compter sur votre
soutien
c'est sûr je battrai pour vous leur
discours très ferme sur l'immigration
séduit instaurer des quotas en système
migratoire à point et surtout sortir de
l'europe
ils sont crédités de 15 % d'intentions
de vote dans cette circonscription
peter whittall affronte spencer du jury
le candidat du parti conservateur
la droite tente de chasser sur les
terres de you keep à leur tour les
conservateurs proposent un référendum
sur l'europe et durcissent le ton sur
l'immigration
david cameron veut une limite plus clair
sur le nombre de personnes vit entre en
grande bretagne mais nous nous voulons
surtout poser des lignes sur le système
social quand on rencontre les électeurs
l'une de leurs principales critiques
c'est que les immigrés viennent réclamer
des aides sociales
nous devons être très clair nous ne
permettrons pas aux gens de profiter du
système ce pays
grande nouveauté de ce scrutin même les
travaillistes font campagne sur ce thème
il propose de renforcer les contrôles
migratoires et de limiter l'accès aux
prestations sociales a deux ans pour les
migrants gareth thomas ce candidat du
labour aux élections justifie ce
revirement
nous voulons sévir contre l'immigration
illégale
nous voulons un contrôle plus strict de
nos frontières pour lutter contre les
passeurs
l'immigration est un vrai sujet et nous
devons avoir un débat politique sur ce
sujet tout en condamnant les attitudes
racistes et xénophobes
ce scrutin est très serré
les conservateurs sont crédités de 30%
comme les travaillistes
aucun n'aurait donc de majorité claire
au parlement et ils devront former une
coalition
you keep pourrait alors rentrer en jeu
grâce aux alliances et poussé le nouveau
gouvernement à durcir sa politique sur
l'immigration
voilà reportage de rim benameur deux
députés européens britanniques nous ont
rejoints jean lambert
bonjour vous êtes membre du green party
à le parti des verts à vos côtés richard
corbett du parti travailliste
bonjour donc on va pas refaire la
campagne britannique ici d'abord vous
êtes député européen je voulais vous
poser une question sur ces naufrages en
méditerranée de ces migrants qui veulent
aller vers l'eldorado européen souvent
britannique une réaction c'est bien
clair que ces naufrages sont taries
c'est rien de nouveau moi j'étais à
lampedusa et après ce qu'ils ont
maintenant et c'est toujours la même
chose il ya des comme on dit en anglais
les larmes de crocodile c'est très
triste mais en fait pas grand chose et
je crois qu'on doit améliorer le lait
d'eau méditerranée mais on doit donner
aussi une possibilité de voeux vient
venir en europe pour trouver l'asile et
ça c'est hors de question ce moment les
chars c'est évidemment épouvantable
j'espère quand même que ça va réveiller
l'europe
il s'est quand même un problème commun
on peut dire que c'est un problème
italien grec c'est un problème commun
on doit agir ensemble la grande bretagne
a peu réagi à sa manière quand même à
calais dans le port de calais elle a
construit à grand guingamp grillage en
france pour empêcher les migrants de
passer c'est une autre question
son pendant de débattre au christ couler
comme un tout à fait différent c'est des
gens qui sont déjà entrés dans l'union
européenne il s'agit de voir dans donc
quel pays aurait dû aurait dû procéder à
leur examen initial de garnements de
d'entrée revenons au sujet qui nous
intéresse on a vu dans le reportage de
rim benameur nature j'ai beaucoup
d'immigrés installé près près de londres
ils disent que l'immigré fait peur en
grande bretagne est-ce qu'ils ont raison
ce qui à du racisme en grande bretagne
où c'est clair il ya du racisme en grand
beau temps je crois que ça c'est en
tentant d'augmenter à cause d'eux
le débat dont le corps la campagne
électorale même avant il ya vraiment une
une idée que d'être immigrés c'est
quelque chose dont on ne doit pas être
ici on cherche à l'argent sans rien
faire et c'est pas la réalité mais je
crois que ça a augmenté pendant la
campagne électorale
oui jacques veyrat pas tout le monde
heureusement à cette attitude mais une
grande minorité et uk très mal
il essaie de jouer sur ça et de lier ça
à l'union européenne
en fait la majorité des migrants au
royaume uni viennent dehors de l'union
européenne au phare à gilly à oui tout
ça c'est à cause de la libre circulation
en europe il ya autant de britanniques
dans les autres états membres de l'union
européenne qui lie à de récentes y sont
européens au royaume uni cet équilibre
est en crise
ils peuvent bien plus sans contribution
fiscale qu'ils ne coûtent à l'état donc
du point de vue du nombre du point de
vue du coup c'est une bénéfice au pour
la grande bretagne lire et le royaume
uni les phares âge très marin essaye de
retourner ce débat vous parlez de nigel
farrage le patron de youtube mais ed
miliband le chef du parti travailliste
lui même veut renforcer le contrôle
migratoire
il l'a dit est ce que c'est devenu une
obsession nationale est ce que le
royaume uni va devenir une forteresse ya
quand même des différences et il a connu
quelques parties travaillent se faire
regarder un aspect très particulier chez
nous beaucoup de prestations sociales
sont de santé sont financées par la
fiscalité par des contributions dont la
plupart des pays il faut d'abord avoir
contribué avant de pouvoir bénéficier
chez nous ce n'est pas le cas pour tout
et pour tout les choses chez nous et on
dit seulement qu il faudrait que les
migrants qui arrivent chez nous attendre
et contribuer par là pour la fiscalité
pendant un certain temps avant de
pouvoir bénéficier autrement tous les
migrants de la reprise de venir chez
nous mais c'est un pas un problème
pas du tout la même chose que veulent
les racistes ou you clip où ce genre de
partie alors la campagne elle bat son
plein chez chez les grands comme parti
travailliste ou le parti conservateur
même chez les petits votre parti le
green party avec un spot électoral
votre parti a mis le paquet le spot
cartonne dans les réseaux sociaux
regardez
celle en deux
kim et ça donne
c
et
les temps changent de thune ou changer
la politique bien sûr et on a fait avec
notre moteur c'est quelque chose de
légères mais avec massages à c'est quoi
le message principal mécène principal
c'est quoi votre je sais quoi qui vous
différencie par rapport aux grands
partis traditionnels comme le parti
travailler dans cette élection c'est ce
que nous disons c'est que l'austérité
c'est pas léger au ces on doit investir
ou gens on doit investir au futur et
c'est pas seulement question de le
déficit de etc on doit investir et c'est
le futur qui compte le charcot bête sur
le sur le front de l'emploi pourtant ça
marche bien en grande bretagne 5 7% du
taux de chômage et des jeunes qui se
précipitent vers londres pour travailler
ça marche bien le problème c'est qu'il
ya beaucoup d'emplois précaires très
précaire et il ya aussi de grands
problèmes dans nos services publics en
particulier services de santé donc on a
pu augmenter le nombre mais sur le dos
de créer d'autres problèmes
et quand on parle d'austérité nous aussi
parti travailliste on est contre
l'austérité
mais en dix ans en même temps que le
déficit on s'en fout on sait qu'un
déficit trop grand en augmentant les
dettes après un certain temps la plupart
de vos recettes fiscales parti pour leur
payer les dettes et les taux d'intérêt
ce haut lieu de se financer les services
publics et l'investissement
donc il faut un équilibre là il faut
diminuer les déficits mais pas en
coupant tous les défenses social pas du
tout
christian neuhaus et en augmentant la
fiscalité sur les prix les plus hauts
revenus
d'accord alors sur l'europe david
cameron a promis un d'un référendum pour
ou contre le maintien de son pays donc
la grande bretagne dans l'europe
est ce que vous pensez sérieusement que
le royaume uni un avenir en dehors de
l'union européenne jean lambert
je crois que c'est tout à fait possible
qu'on va quitter leur allant c'est
possible
cette fois ci un cépage et si on voit ce
que disent les partis qu'on va y occupe
et c est aussi le grand public
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelques fois une
majorité presque me sentais mou la
population britannique et à peu aux
sceptiques ou anti européenne oui je
crois que c'est possible et c'est aussi
possible que si on regarde qui votent
dans l'élection
elle peut être aussi dans le référendum
c'est plus que les gens plus âgés qui
sont plutôt contre le rang et par les
jeunes qui sont plutôt pour l'europe
donc si on peut faire quelque chose
comme dans le référendum monaco et corse
par exemple où il y avait plein de monde
qui étaient allés voter alors peut-être
il ya un autre résultat mais c'est tout
à fait possible à mon avis les gens
peuvent rien
aussi le sinistre que il ya un risque
mais quand même ce serait le suicide
économique est un désastre politique
donc j'espère qu'on va quand même se
ressaisir ce que cherche comme nous
c'est d'unifier son parti qui est très
divisé sur leur opinion in hell qui veut
quitter une aile qui pense que tout ça
c'est fou on aurait dit qu'on va voir ça
après on va renégocier et on fera encore
un référendum en fait ce qu'ils
demandent c'est deux fois du chantage
il va d'abord dire aux autres pays ont
changé l'europe comme ça où on quitte et
c'est vrai ensuite il va d'ailleurs au
britannique il faut accepter ce nouvel
europe que je négociais ou creed et le
statu quo ne sera pas sur le bulletin de
vote ou une autre série de réformes
ce sera l'ordre cameron conservateur ou
rien et à ce moment là il va dire il
faut accepter ce que j'ai négocié parce
que kitty ce serait quand même la folie
on parlait aussi d'émergence de ceux de
ce parti you keep est ce que c'est un
parti populiste comme les autres
nationale et nine nigel de faras ne veut
pas faire de groupe ici au parlement
européen avec les élus du front national
est-ce que c'est comme les autres où est
la différence
il ya sont très similaires dans le même
point de vue au front national
évidemment pour des raisons tactiques
qui veut pas s ils veulent pas s'allier
se voit ici au parlement renferme une
grande partie des partis d'extrême
droite hills ils prennent tous qui n'ont
rien à faire avec les autres les autres
ces extrémistes nous se demanderait ce
n'est pas mon frère je voyais réagir
dans le sujet de rim benameur quand le
candidat du parti ue qui parlait de de
racisme ou essais et ils ont toujours la
chaussée si on parle
il réclame que si on parle de
l'immigration on est nommé raciste non
c'est pas vrai c'est qu'on on parle de
l'immigration si on est raciste et je
crois que deux trois ans avant c'était
clair ça c'était le mouvement des
liquides maintenance a changé et ils ont
changé ils ont changé leur vie changer
la chanson mais ils ont plein de
problèmes dans le parti parce qu'il y à
vraiment les gens qui sont tout à fait
contre l'immigration qui sont tout à
fait contre les immigrés et à d autres
qui ne sont pas comme ça donc c'est
évident on aura compris que ce sera donc
à un thème de campagne principale pour
ces élections législatives en grande
bretagne qui auront lieu le 7 mai
prochain je ne rappelle jean lamberton
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
richard corbett merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
je perds je vous propose de terminer
cette émission avec avec ces images un
groupe de défenseurs des droits de
l'homme a organisé un rassemblement et
une veillée devant le parlement européen
à bruxelles en mémoire des migrants qui
ont péri en méditerranée dans le
naufrage de leur navire
certains ont apporté des fleurs d'autres
déposer des bateaux en papier sur le sol
tout en appelant à une couverture des
frontières
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission non
tout ce qu'ils ont préparée je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi à rester avec
nous sur les chaînes parlementaires